what tips would you give somebody who
has trouble mentally clocking out of
work can I talk stop what you just said
I call bullcrap on it man you can stop
you're choosing not to and so this idea
that we are this powerless slave to this
four inch by three inch metal box is
nonsense it's not true and as long as we
hang on to this narrative that they in
these Silicon Valley guys have got us
stop do whatever it takes put insane
hurdles throw it off a bridge Smash It
buried underwater turn it off right give
it to a friend put a passcode what have
you got to do but stop with that
narrative that I can't I can't I can't I
can't I can't that narrative is
paralyzing all of us it's not working
that story's not working